Well,
this is it.
Our last direct message before Donald
trump is sworn in as the 45th president
of the United States,
according to half of the media and
countless celebrities,
January 20th will be the beginning of
the Armageddon.
According to trump supporters and lots
of anime avatars on twitter.
January 20th will be the single greatest
day in world history.
I however,
think that the truth lies somewhere in
between the bloviation of Michael Moore
and the memes of pepe.
The frog in the space between these two
extremes is some incredibly fertile
ground for those of us who want to make
this country sane again.
Think about it.
When was the last time you felt that
there was so much going on that was
changing the world all around us all at
once?
Maybe you're thinking back to eight
years ago when Barack Obama ran on hope
and change,
but actually think that there's more
opportunity right now than there was.
Then we can debate whether Obama was a
good president or not.
I'd say pretty much yes on domestic
policy and basically no on the
international front,
but in terms of actual change,
did much really changed or did the
system just keeps chugging along.
By the way,
I don't have much of a problem with that
system chugging along.
For all its faults,
our system is still a pretty great one,
but if change was what you wanted eight
years ago,
I'm not really sure that's what you got
with trump though.
There can be no doubt that change is
coming.
Everything about trump from the way he
debated his tweets,
his cabinet picks have been different
than anything before.
You may not like any of his tactics are
his choices,
but you can't argue that change isn't
happening right now.
This very second,
and if you don't like the change that
you see,
it is your duty as a citizen to have
your voice heard.
Get out their protests or volunteer,
be part of the process with which you
are so upset right now.
Of course,
by the same token,
if you're happy,
trump won and you think he's the answer
to political correctness and the rest of
society's ills,
then you're about to be tested to.
It's one thing to be against political
correctness and for free speech when
you're in the opposition,
but it takes real character to be
against political correctness and for
free speech when it's your guy that the
words are aimed at.
I think that most of you who watched the
show aren't really on either one of
these teams and instead care more about
principles then party.
Actually,
I really believe it's not just you
watching this channel who believed this,
but it's pretty much everyone out there
who isn't on the Democratic or
Republican payroll.
Many republicans made it clear they
wouldn't work with Obama,
which lead to gridlock,
which led to trump.
Now,
many Democrats are making it clear that
they won't work with trump,
which really just makes them as bad as
the Republicans they have been
complaining about for the past eight
years.
This isn't how our system is supposed to
work.
By constantly being held hostage by two
parties who care more about stopping the
other one from succeeding than doing
anything positive in themselves.
This is clearly where we are.
However,
and this is why change,
real change is needed now more than
ever.
The change shouldn't be about whether
you vote for a Democrat or vote for a
Republican,
though it should be about how much power
we give any of these people to control
our lives.
Violent protests,
which unfortunately I think we're going
to have more and more of will only bring
more authoritarianism and state power.
We need to change attitudes and win the
battle of ideas,
not just the battle of the day.
That's why I've spent the last year and
a half talking about having honest
conversations and dealing with difficult
topics.
Every time we forego real debate and
silence our opponents,
we spawn a new set of people who will
come in with easy answers.
This is the space that the true bigots
and actual authoritarians will flourish
in.
It doesn't matter if they're far
leftists who want to silence.
Critics are far rightists who want to
kick out immigrants.
They don't want conversation,
they want control.
It's also why I'm completely convinced
that a new center is developing faster
than even we realized traditional labels
are becoming increasingly meaningless as
people realize that the battle is no
longer democrat versus Republican,
nor is it us verse them.
The battle lines are now those who are
truly for freedom versus those who would
stifle it in the name of tolerance or
the name of security.
Thanks to the Internet though,
and the rising group of voices who are
calling out this nonsense.
We're starting to win some of these
battles and if trump has taught us
anything,
people like a winter.
Well,
Alright Donald,
you won.
So now it's time to do some real
interviews and respond to some real
criticism.
I've got a chair for you right there.
So while maybe I've lost the left or the
left has lost me,
I now see that fertile ground that I'm
going to start planting some seeds.
These seeds will not only be to grow new
alliances with liberals and
conservatives,
but even Marxists and progressives,
I have no desire to silence them or any
of the people I disagree with.
I want to continue to talk about the
ideas which will help us avoid that
whole pesky armageddon thing that I
mentioned earlier.
We can do this together,
not by d platforming and through
violence,
but by consistently showing that the
ideas of freedom and liberty and the
rights of the individual are the best
way to attain a society that values true
human equality.
Joining me this week is author radio
host and is Dennis prager.
A few weeks before the election,
I was at an event for his youtube
channel,
prager university,
and I heard Dennis his keynote speech.
I heard Dennis speak through his
conservative Lens about how the
wonderful experiment that is America and
his deep concern for the future of this
country.
While I know we have our disagreements
about religion,
gay marriage,
abortion,
and a bunch of other things,
I see dentists as someone I can build a
bridge with because he'll honestly tell
me what he believes and I'll do the same
for every liberal that he may convert to
conservatism.
I think I can convert just as many
conservatives to liberalism and as I
said before,
these labels are becoming more and more
meaningless by the day.
It doesn't matter if we agree on every
little thing.
What matters is that will defend the
other person's right to liberty and
freedom.
As we enter this new phase of change,
it'll be up to us as to whether the
change is positive or negative.
Our system is stronger than one man,
but one man can change the world.
Let's trade hope and change for the
courage of our convictions and let the
chips fall where they may.
Joining me this week is an author,
a nationally syndicated radio host,
a columnist,
and the creator of Prager University,
right here on the youtube,
Dennis prager.
Welcome to the Rubin report
to be with you,
so somehow we've only met once,
although I feel that we're in the same
space and that I know you sort of just
through your public self,
but the one time we met we were on Larry
King's show on my own home aura and you
know,
they bring you on as the conservative
and they brought me on as the liberal
and I think it was a little bit around
my kind of waking up to what was
happening with the left and we kind of
agreed on a lot.
Not on everything,
but we agreed on a lot.
Do you find that odd that sometimes you
can agree with a liberal because you are
a conservative?
Oh,
I couldn't agree with a liberal.
I can't agree with a leftist.
I make the distinction between liberal
left constantly because it needs to be
made.
The left is an enemy of liberalism and I
love liberalism on cold,
a conservative.
But the irony is I don't know pretty
much of any value that I changed since I
was a liberal.
Remember,
uh,
I was born in New York,
but a,
be a Jew,
see Columbia.
So that's exactly,
that's a lot of democratic stuff.
That's Riley's.
Exactly.
So that was a given to me.
You were all those three things.
It's like,
I always say on my birth certificate,
it had,
you know,
on the days when you still had gender,
gender,
Male,
you know,
political affiliation,
liberal or Democrat.
So it was just a given.
But I haven't changed my values that the
left has taken over the word liberal.
And so therefore I consider those values
inimical to everything liberalism stood
for.
So one of the things that I've been
saying is that lately defending my
liberal values is becoming a
conservative position.
Now I suspect that's what,
that's what I'm saying.
What you felt when,
when did that change for you?
So we changed.
For me,
there were two seminal issues.
I knew I was not on the left when,
during the Vietnam War,
which I was in college and I knew
communism was evil and my life is
devoted to fighting evil.
That's what I care about more than
anything.
I hate people who hurt people
deliberately.
I hate them.
I want them destroyed.
I want evil destroyed.
I have a,
I have not wavered in that passion since
high school.
That's all I really.
I mean,
I care about a million things,
but that's my greatest care.
I want to destroy evil.
Nazi-Ism,
communism,
Islamism,
you name it.
Uh,
and the left didn't.
The left hated Nazis,
but they didn't hate communists.
So it meant they didn't hate evil.
And that's my first realization that I
wasn't on the left.
So,
but I still thought I was a liberal but
not on the left.
And then Ronald Reagan came and in one
sentence it all turned for me and then I
became a Republican.
And that was a government is not the
solution.
It's the problem.
Um,
and that was an epiphany and I thought
that's right.
There are truths that are so real that
if you have an open mind,
it doesn't take more than five seconds
to realize it.
Does that necessarily make you a
republican or does that really just make
you a classical liberal?
And I know I always say on this show,
I have to use a lot of these terms that
I think are starting to lose meaning,
but we need them just to have labels.
That's fine.
But.
So what made you then say,
okay,
well now I'm a Republican because that
you could use that Reagan quote and say,
well,
I'm a classical liberal.
It's individually in limited government.
Yes.
But the home for classical liberalism is
the Republican party to the extent that
they're not big government people,
which George W Bush was,
for example,
but the only home between Democrats and
Republicans for limited government
people is the Republican Party.
Do you sense that changing now?
Obviously we're gonna have to talk a
little bit about trump here.
Uh,
I think at first maybe you weren't
supporting him and then you
progressionally were.
And then I think basically you supported
him.
Is that.
Yeah,
I just don't want it.
Well,
I,
I actually,
uh,
I'm proud to say all the time will tell
whether I will be proud to say yeah,
but I was thoroughly consistent.
I was opposed to him the most among all
the Republicans.
And I wrote piece after piece in
National Review Town Hall and other
places where my column appears,
I wa,
I was anti trump as anyone,
but I wrote from my first column,
if he wins the nomination,
I will vote for him.
And My,
my thinking was clear in retrospect was
clear.
Uh,
I,
I kept giving this analogy.
If you have two doors over one door,
it says man eating lion and over the
other it says maybe a man I will open
the maybe a man eating lion.
I don't see it as a big dilemma.
So this really was more of a reflection
of your feelings on hillary than
anything else.
No,
no,
no.
It's that feelings on the left,
defeating the left is as great a moral
urgency as defeating Islam.
Islam.
Those are the two,
uh,
enemies of Western civilization as we
know it.
And I say that I would sadness there
were a lot of Nice people on the left.
Uh,
the probably not that many Nice
Islamicists all the grid that.
But there isn't.
This wouldn't be too thrilled about
this.
Uh,
they would not go to Brooklyn born Jews.
Well,
the left wouldn't be too thrilled with
the seat.
We're going to get into a little bit of
that,
but I mean it sincerely.
Look,
look at what they're doing to the
university.
The university is now becoming a fishing
stick place literally,
uh,
with the,
with the old semi cuase I violent
suppression of dissenting voices.
And the reason it is the only place the
left runs without opposition.
So when the left is free to do what it
wants,
just look at your local university and
you see what's happening.
Okay?
So then
what's happening there?
What do you think is in the mind?
And I was around these people a lot for
a long time and I don't know that I have
the right answer to this.
What is happening,
where they have created this system of
what now I'm calling the oppression
Olympics where you know,
your hood is the highest virtue that you
can have and we have to place
everybody's victim hood below yours
because that means you're better than
them and all that stuff.
What happened there?
What,
where did this come from?
Well,
for one,
there are many,
many,
and it's very hard.
Analyzing the left has been as complex
to me as you know,
the,
the search for string theory is among
physicists.
It because it's so emotional that there
isn't the logical consistency for one
answer to your question is the,
the left does not divide the world
between good and bad.
I do,
uh,
but the left doesn't.
The left divides up between rich and
poor and strong and weak,
uh,
so,
or,
or victim and victimizer.
So you get,
you don't get your strength from being
right.
You get your strength from being a
victim,
from being the underdog.
That's the reason the leftist,
Pro Palestinian.
Anyone with a moral compass that works
some of the time knows that there was no
comparison between Israel and the
Palestinians morally speaking,
but the left routes for the Palestinians
because not because they don't measure
by good and bad,
they measure by weakened strong black
and white,
west and non west,
first world and third world,
but not good and evil.
So that's a big factor that's taking
place on the campus.
How do you define good and evil before
you go the same way,
the same way you do?
I mean it,
it's not a trick issue.
A good is treating people decently,
is having an openness to a opposing
views without suppressing them,
uh,
is not building concentration camps.
I mean it's.
This is not.
This is not rocket science.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So last time I saw you was at a prager
university event and you gave the
keynote speech was the keynote speech
and I,
it was right before the election and I
sensed that you actually do want to
build some bridges with these people,
which is probably partially why.
Why were sitting down that you weren't.
I didn't think you were really clear.
You don't like what's happening with the
modern left,
but I do sense that you're trying to
figure out a way to reach out to some of
these people,
which is what you're doing with prager
u.
are you seeing any real attraction and
waking some of these people up?
All the,
I know we're waking people up because
there was no,
not one of the 150 prager university
videos.
They're all journal,
five minutes,
just some burly fine fingers.
Give them not one of them yells at you.
It's a,
hey,
here is our position,
here is the reason and here are the
facts behind it and have a wonderful
day.
So isn't it funny that that became not
the norm?
I mean,
people say to me all the time,
I Love Your Show because you Aka people.
That's right.
Well,
I get that.
Do you know why get that's funny.
You should say that I've been
broadcasting 33 years and the most
common among the most common,
maybe it is the most,
or it's among the most common reactions
I get.
God,
you know,
what I really love about your show is
you're calm.
You know,
you never yell.
In fact,
I do yell about four times a year where
something will get me so angry maybe six
times a year.
And I always apologize because I read
readers,
listeners tell me we love it when you
yell because it's so rare and they
realize you know,
you,
you can really,
you can prick me and I'll bleed.
But,
uh,
it's,
I just can't stand yelling.
Yeah,
well to me it's sort of like a well
placed fuck,
I don't say it that often.
Even just saying it now,
I probably haven't said it on air and in
quite some time,
but that I brought it out.
You,
you see,
you the way you,
it
rage me here that you've.
So you feel like you have made some
traction because you're,
you're hearing from people that are
saying,
wow,
there's some.
The problem is,
and it is a problem veet veet.
Uh,
um,
what's the word?
Uh,
uh,
when,
when you're not taught,
you are indoctrinated.
The indoctrination of,
of American kids begin so early.
You're taught now in third grade,
you are taught in,
in many of the states about carbon
emissions.
They don't show them a Bjorn Lomborg
video saying that we're wasting
trillions of dollars to lower the
temperature by a fraction of a degree.
They don't show them because they don't
believe there are other sides.
There are truth tellers and deniers.
They are truth tellers are anti science.
By the way.
One of the things was I studied leftism.
That was my,
uh,
I,
I studied communist affairs marks
leftism,
and one of the things that they have
always excelled at is one word
dismissals of their ideological enemies.
So Stalin Trotsky,
Trotsky the father of Bolshevism.
He called him a fascist.
So Trotsky was a fascist.
There was no need to debate Trotsky.
You call him a fascist and then have him
killed with an ice.
Pick that.
And that's,
that's in a nutshell what the left six
herb,
sexist intolerant,
xenophobic,
homophobic,
Islamophobic,
racist,
bigoted.
There was no need to think on the left
because you have a one word dismissal of
your opponents.
Yeah.
So,
so far I know that 90 percent of my
audience listening to this is going to
go,
all right,
this prager guy for conservative.
This,
this makes sense.
I mean,
you're,
you're hitting the keys that I hit here
all the time.
So what about on something like science,
because you,
you just mentioned sight.
This seems to me where the Republicans
and the right.
It just doesn't add up.
We're still debating evolution.
We're debating climate science.
I'm not a scientist.
I've brought climate scientists in here
who have said in unison,
basically they agree by the way I've had
Alex Epstein is books right there,
a moral case for fossil fuels and I was
happy to talk to him as well and he
takes it from a different angle and I'm
happy to have those
compensation and I don't pretend to know
everything so.
So there you go.
But science to me is one of the things
where the right has just
no gone by.
It's just one of those things where the
left has effectively demonized the
right.
Our position.
I've never met somebody on the right who
said the science is wrong.
It's not solid evolution,
for example.
Okay,
well,
all right,
so you're wanting to evolution.
So evolution is very complex issue.
Believe it or not,
by the way,
I don't have a particular ax to grind.
I happen to believe in God and my
position for most of my life was okay.
God created evolution.
I have no issue.
So concurrently,
that's not my position any longer
because I simply know more science and
that if the science on evolution is not
nearly as established as people think it
is because the,
the,
the paleontologists themselves are not
so certain that it occurred in anywhere
near the way they believe it.
The two,
two quick things on that one is of
course I just,
it's just needs to be stated that
evolution has zero explanation.
I mean zero,
none for the creation of life.
There was no,
there was no evolutionary jump between
inorganic and organic and,
and they acknowledge that they just say
one day they'll find one,
but there isn't one.
So the evolutionist has nothing to say
about the origin of life.
They have something to say about the
origin of species species once life
begins.
But that's a big difference.
The second part is they don't have a lot
to say even on the origin of species.
When you,
when you look at there was this thing
called the Cambrian.
Was it the Cambrian?
My wife knows she's going crazy because
she's in the other one.
She's the real maven on this.
But the,
the k onto an IFA,
Cambrian explosion.
That's an explosion.
Yeah.
This was when vast numbers of species or
rose,
but much too quickly for evolution to
have accounted for them.
And there were so many qualified
scientists who have taken this on.
Even,
uh,
even the famous Harvard paleontologist
is passed away,
uh,
whose name eludes me for the moment,
but he,
he wrote about this.
He was an,
he was an atheist or agnostic,
you know,
but he said he had punctuated evolution
where it,
which is almost an oxymoron because it,
it,
you know,
we're just things per day.
Yeah.
Anyway,
my only point is that it's not as clear
as they make.
Now,
if somebody says to you,
I don't believe that the world was
created in billions of years,
that the,
you know,
the world was created in six days,
24 hour periods,
cold days.
That is a rejection of the science on
the matter.
That's right.
Okay.
So I'm glad you're making that function
because we can.
Neither one of us are evolutionary
biology.
We can say as much as we know.
And that,
by the way,
just for the record,
just today,
I had an interview with Jerry Coyne
who's a world renowned and evolutionary
biologists who would,
I'm sure take issue with some of the
things you're saying here,
but we don't have to bicker over those
little things,
but you're juggling when someone looks
at the literal six day thing and here.
But here,
I just want to say forgive me,
I,
I really.
Yeah,
let's get it.
I don't give a hoot if somebody believes
God created the world in 60 slash 24
hour periods.
I care if they,
if they reject vaccines,
if they don't give blood transfusions.
In other words,
I don't care what people believe.
I care how people behave.
This a very important principle in my
life.
So if you happen to believe that God
created the world,
which I don't because the science and
the gates it.
But if you believe,
and I believe that the Bible is,
is divine and all that good stuff,
but uh,
but nevertheless,
uh,
if you do believe that it here,
it is possible to be a professor of
medicine and believe God created the
world in six days.
I know that sounds oxymoronic,
but it isn't religious belief is
religious belief and scientific belief,
a scientific belief for many people.
I like to reconcile them,
but some just say I'm not reconciling
them.
This is what it says.
I take it and now I would like to go
back to my,
uh,
medical lab police to do a research on,
on,
on cancer.
Right?
So in,
in some way though,
is that reconciliation sort of splitting
the difference of what you truly believe
me,
Dennis?
Yeah.
No,
I believe in science and religion.
I don't think that there's a conflict at
all.
Truth is truth.
There's a Hebrew saying,
the signature of God is truth.
If something is true,
I must believe it because it's true.
I am religiously obligated to believe it
if it's true.
Right?
So if a doctor for you,
let's say you had to have heart surgery
or something and you had two doctors to
choose from and,
and they had the same exact,
you know,
medical background.
One of them said,
I believe in evolution and science and
all that stuff.
The other guy said,
well,
you know,
the earth was created in six days and
guy I would flip a coin so that would
have absolutely no role because they can
compartmentalize,
not because I can not
compartmentalizing.
They can because I know.
You see,
here's the interesting thing,
there are a lot of orthodox Jews.
Um,
I'm,
I'm a religious Jew but not orthodox,
but there are a lot of.
So I have,
this is not a no ax to grind.
There were a lot of orthodox Jews who
were doctors who are physicists,
who are chemists,
biologists.
How was that possible?
They believed the tourists from God and
they then go to the lab and do wonderful
scientific work.
So obviously they've lived,
they live with both.
Yeah.
So what does that say about humans in
general?
That we're just able to live with
Commonwealth.
Orion?
I have an interesting theory on that.
Uh,
this is why the left scares me more than
a,
you know,
the,
the leftist scared by religious
Christians,
for example.
I'm not scared by religious Christians
at all.
And,
um,
again,
I emphasize them.
I got,
I got your prager u card.
I mean,
it said Merry Christmas.
I freaked out and I,
you know,
I sent the letter to the FBI,
but I don't know,
I know that not only we were,
we were interviewed,
told us you sent them a,
the,
uh,
the fear that they have is not,
is not comparable.
And here is the theory.
So here's my theory.
I,
the human being clearly needs to beliefs
some non rational things.
I believe that that is part of what the
human mind must have.
So the religious person,
the healthy and I'm talking about
healthy,
religious,
unhealthy,
nonreligious,
apples and apples.
The healthy religious person confines
his non rational thought to religiosity.
The secular person,
when they have the non rational,
they're much scarier because that is not
about splitting of cs or,
or Jesus walking on water.
It's about real life.
The amount of the non rational that is
believed on the left,
that is scary.
So basically a non rational in the
religious realm is not necessarily
scary.
It could be.
You believe you murder people.
You get 72 virgins.
That scary.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of people that believe
you're right.
That's why he used Christians.
America was founded by fundamentalist
Christians who produced and incredibly
rational society.
Uh,
and uh,
the,
the competitive marketplace,
the free market liberty,
these were very rational ideas.
They were very religious men.
Not all but many of them were.
So,
uh,
you know,
I,
I and I,
I welcome secularism in Iran and I fear
secularism in America.
Right?
That's it.
I mean,
there's something really there between
those two things.
We probably have the rights society,
I suppose.
Yeah.
So it's interesting because I see this
constantly and I'm sure you see it too,
this constant attacking of straight
white men have Christians.
All of these things.
And what you're saying basically is we
were born out of Christianity,
America and we've become absurdly
tolerant and yet everyone,
not absurdly time.
And I think it's wonderfully unique.
Uniquely right,
and yet we have,
there's just this idea out there that we
are the most intolerant place.
How do you,
how do you fight those ideas back?
How,
how,
how you fight the irrational is very
hard.
It's very hard because you can give
evidence.
I give evidence for America being the
least racist society that had multi
racial elements in it,
in history,
and it doesn't,
doesn't convince people who have.
If people have a vested interest in
believing something,
you can't talk them out of it,
and this is why I fear the left.
They have the,
the world would collapse it.
It is like the.
The famous book written when Stalin made
this pact with Hitler.
All these communists in the left who
would followed,
who had followed Stalin.
Not all,
many of them thought,
oh my God,
I've been believing in nonsense my whole
life.
The God that failed.
That's a very famous book from I think
the fifties or maybe the forties and
and,
and it was about that,
that the,
the left.
Why do people believe in communism?
I mean it,
it is,
it is drivel thing is drivel,
but when people drop Judeo Christian
religions,
Catholicism Protestantism,
evangelicalism,
mormonism,
Judaism,
when people drop those,
they don't stop yearning for certitude,
so what they end up with is secular,
religious,
certitudes,
and they are at least as scary,
so I don't think you would quite word it
this way,
but I guess I would wear it as they get
their letting go of the sort of easier
answers that religion might provide and
then it's a little easier to sway them
in the secular arena.
Would you say that to say?
Although I don't think you would wear to
quite that.
That's one.
It's fine and it's also easier for
another reason.
Secularism makes no moral demands on
you,
tells you there is no God who judges
you.
So it's also you feel great about
yourself by taking the right position on
any left wing issue.
I love.
I love blacks,
I love gays,
I love Muslims.
I love whoever the victim of the month
is and I'm a wonderful human being.
My daughter is a great girl.
Really?
The she cheat on tests.
I don't know,
but she does in fact,
uh,
she,
does 10 k run for breast cancer.
That doesn't make you a daughter,
a good girl.
That's a very sweet thing that she does.
But uh,
uh,
you are,
you are judged by your character,
right?
And there's no more character emphasis.
So I suspect since you live here in la,
that you're friends with probably a lot
of completely secular nonbelievers,
uh,
who may not even,
you might not even know they're
nonbelievers.
So what's the part that I'm missing?
I consider myself totally secular.
I try to live by some sense of morality
and whatever.
And then like everyone else,
I fail at it sometimes,
but what's the piece that you can't stay
on,
on the good path,
so to speak,
without religion?
Well,
there are many.
There are many.
I mean,
why can't,
why you know that I be glued to my
neighbor and partner and those types of,
as I say,
a billion times,
this is really critical.
If there's no god,
there's no good and evil.
There are only opinions about good and
evil.
Having said that,
there are,
they're a wonderful atheists and
agnostics,
secular and there were terrible
religious people.
I know that,
but if you want the long term survival
of a good society,
it cannot be done without God.
It will,
it will,
it will be an utter failure.
And the failure in Europe,
Europe is a failing society.
It,
it,
it because it doesn't stand up for
anything.
It stands for nothing.
Europe's stands for nothing except for
feeling good about its own morality for
it's socialism,
for,
you know,
uh,
we'll,
we'll take care of,
of the,
of everybody with a safety net that we
can pay for.
So we'll bring in millions of Muslims
who will a decrease,
denies a and D Westernized Society and
there will be no Europe in,
in 20,
40 years.
That's what's happening.
America actually cares about retaining
the Judeo Christian bases because it
knows what,
what George Washington said in his
farewell address,
you or,
or was it the second inaugural?
No second year old is Lincoln.
But what he said,
I guess the farewell address.
Anybody who thinks that a,
you can have a survival of morality
without religion is thinking foolishly,
and this guy was no fundamentalist.
Uh,
but,
but the,
the founders understood no garden of
liberty.
No God,
no small government,
no god,
no good and evil.
So yes,
the people like you,
I have no doubt that you're a good pr.
I mean,
I'm not the of a little louder.
I don't know.
I don't even have a little doubt.
You,
you strike me as for a whole host of
reasons,
a very decent and an inquiring mind and
so on.
I know that exists,
but you weren't the product of the Judeo
Christian system that you no longer hold
by.
So my question to you is,
what's going to pass this on to
generation after generation and it's not
being passed.
The vast majority of kids today,
indeed for the last 25,
30 years,
would save their dog before a human
because they love their dog and they
don't love the stranger.
They say it.
They're proudly announced I would save
my dog because we don't have objective
morality which says,
man is created in God's image.
Dogs or not,
we have subjective morality.
What do you love?
I love my dog.
So this must have put you in a strange
position with trump though,
because I think out of all of the
Republicans that you could've chosen,
right?
You certainly could have said Ted Cruz,
you certainly could have said Marco
Rubio said he probably,
he was my last choice,
but he,
but he's the only one who could have
defeated the left.
So,
so that concept of defeating that,
that even superseded what supersedes
everything right now.
The left is so neolistic of force in the
world that,
uh,
it,
it almost anything supersedes.
I mean,
there was a level of evil that I
wouldn't vote for,
obviously a to even to the feet the
left.
But uh,
but there,
there was no such living Republican.
Right?
So for,
let's say a long time fan of yours that
I'm sure you got emails like this that
said,
all right,
I know prager.
He's,
he's moral and he's decent and all of
these things he's voting for a guy are
now supporting.
Right?
I get that a lot.
He's now supporting a guy who will say
anything.
He wants tweets.
All this crazy stuff is a narcissist,
but I don't know what is moral
centuries.
I mean,
that's what I kept saying the entire
time is I just don't know what the guy,
his moral center is.
I think there's a chance where things
are going to be great.
Yeah,
I didn't know his moral said.
That's why I said there were two doors,
man eating lie and the Democrat,
maybe a man eating lion.
That's trump.
So between maybe indefinite,
of course I'll vote for maybe.
Right.
So then is this just a completely unique
political situation?
Is there anything in your life that you
can remember?
Uh,
there was an article in one of the major
papers today,
I don't know if it was the times or the
Wall Street Journal,
but one of them,
uh,
about the uniqueness.
This is a whole new episode.
It was like Jackson,
Andrew Jackson transformed the country.
FDR transform the country.
This might be one of those
transformative moments.
It might be the end of the,
of at least one of the parties as we
know it.
There are a whole host of things that
could happen.
I don't know what'll happen.
I do know this though,
that uh,
and I say this to the conservatives who
call in and are still sort of never
trumpers.
I said,
if somebody would have given you his
cabinet list a year ago and said,
we don't know who the nominee will be,
but this will be the cabinet while would
you have said.
And they would have said we would have
been ecstatic.
Right.
So ironically,
he ended up going more conservative,
incorrect in his cabinet then he ran on.
That's correct.
He's got the,
he's got the trump people,
the Manga people are annoyed at him
about the cabinet and the Conservatives
are going,
well,
I don't know if the trump people are.
Well,
because I think there's a sense that
maybe it's a little more,
uh,
no.
Well,
they have their own power sort of are
the people who were not conservative,
who voted for him don't care who he
points to cabinet.
They care whether we improves the
economy.
Do you think there's a danger in just
the way the cult of personality around
him that we have a leader,
that it really is superseding logic and
reason and even if you end up liking
some of the things and he lowered some
taxes and we don't get involved in crazy
military things,
do you think just that,
that Culta personality now?
We certainly had it with Obama too.
That was a different way answered my
question.
Yes,
I answered my question.
Your question.
That's well said.
Yes.
It'll be very difficult to match the
amount of,
of cultiness around Obama.
So the change,
this is what I mentioned at the,
at the top of the show before you sat
down that the change Obama came in with
hope and change in a certain respect.
There wasn't a lot of change.
He did some things.
He changed.
So.
So what are some of the things that he
changed?
He changed
what,
what percentage of the economy?
His health and he changed that to move
toward a one,
a one payer economy.
That was a huge change.
Uh,
I think he,
I think everything he changed.
I think he did,
he,
he changed America's role in the world
to being,
becoming a bystander.
You know,
uh,
Assad,
there's a red line in Syria if you use
chemical biological weapons.
So he uses those weapons.
Nothing happens.
Uh,
so it's a green light to,
we ran,
do whatever you want in Syria.
Russia takes over Crimea.
Gee,
that's really unfortunate.
Uh,
on what?
I still won't arm the Ukrainian
government.
Uh,
so he,
he,
he is back down in every incident than
the agreement with Iran.
The only government in the world that
isn't announced that wishes to commit
genocide.
I mean,
that's a pretty,
pretty significant.
Uh,
and,
and court is a great Tome Mutek phrase,
those who are kind to the cruel,
be cruel to the kind.
So the nicer he got to Iran and unlike
my and Castro,
the,
the tougher he got onto Tanya,
who,
so this is classic rule of history.
It's a 2000 old from the Talmud.
Those who are kind to the cruel,
be cruel to the kind of Obama and the
left perfectly encapsulate that vision.
So I suspect I know your answer to this,
but going to Israel for just a second,
you're a big defender of Israel.
I saw your,
I think you did a video before prager u
about Israel.
Did you do saying that?
That was.
Okay.
So that was even before I knew about
that was a viral one.
Yeah.
Where you gave,
I thought a very thoughtful,
historically accurate version of what
the truth is.
And,
and you know the big line I think.
Well let you say that line.
Basically what you say about the other
side Pid and the headline was yes,
if tomorrow is real announced we are
fighting no more.
We are disbanding our army,
we are dismantling our armaments a what
would happen the next day and if the
Arabs announced,
you know,
we are laying down our arms,
we are fighting Israel no more.
What would happen the next day in that
scenario,
one of the first scenario they would be
genocide Israel.
Israelis would be wiped out.
They would be mass murder,
torture and rape in the streets of
Israel.
The on the other scenario,
there would be peace within a week.
Yeah,
so I,
I basically agree with that.
And so,
so what is the obsession with Israel?
I mean,
as I pointed out the day of the century
in the world.
Yeah,
the especially the world.
As I pointed out the day of the Kerry
speech,
I posted a image of the entire Middle
East with one little orange sliver
amongst all of this other stuff.
And this thing is tiny.
We,
we're talking about at one point,
I think including the West Bank nine
miles wide at one point,
you know,
you could have rocky,
they have one international airport,
but one place where gays and atheists
and Christians and the high and all of
these people,
it's the only place where you can see an
orthodox Jewish man on a bus sitting
next to a woman in a hijab.
I mean,
it's the one place in coexistence and
they're obsessed with it.
And this is where I feel like I've
completely lost left.
I have tried desperately to bring some
clarity to this and I don't know that I
can.
What,
what's the obsession?
What's in the final analysis you have
really hit,
uh,
my one of my deepest beliefs in life.
And it's a religious belief,
a Jew,
hatred and Israel hatred is Jew hatred,
not criticism of Israel.
Nobody ever.
No one has ever said if you criticize,
is really are an antisemite,
but if you support those who wish to
destroy Israel,
whether you feel that you're a Jew,
hater or not is irrelevant.
If you say,
I want Italy destroyed,
you can say I'm not anti Italian.
Okay,
so why?
Of all the 200 plus countries on earth
is only one targeted for destruction.
And by sheer coincidence,
it's the only Jewish country in the
world.
Why?
Of all the people in the world is only
one bid targeted for true genocide.
We speak genocide here,
genocide,
the genocide everywhere.
But the one true genocide take every
baby.
Every child,
every grandparent who was a Jew and
gassed them,
slaughter them,
shoot them,
bury them.
Only Jews,
Jew hatred is the own.
I wrote a book on this called why the
Jews,
Jew hatred is the only hatred that is
extermination list.
That's very important.
Whites who hated blacks did not wish to
exterminate all blacks you name,
and it's a terrible hatred.
It's not a defensive it,
but there was no other.
There was a desire to wipe out the Jews
and the desire to wipe out Israel is
part of the desire to wipe out the Jews.
And it is,
it is.
It is a reason that I believe in the
truth ultimately of the biblical
narrative,
especially the first five books of the
Torah,
that,
that when God chose the Jews,
this chosen,
this led them to be the world's hated
people because they ended up the
conscience of the world.
So is the irony that I think if you
took,
I think you've talked about this,
I'm sure you have talked about this and
I think it was one of your books
actually,
that if you took most Jews in America,
they're totally secular.
They've sorted,
I think most are totally left this.
So I think Ben Shapiro is Trey Trey,
he's.
He says,
uh,
they've traded their religiosity for
lefties.
I think.
Ben Shapiro.
Oh yeah.
I've been saying it's in spending,
but not from valley before.
I was born.
Yeah,
but that's,
but that is exactly right.
And Ben is right and whoever says it is
right.
The,
uh,
the Jews,
Jew,
Jews are.
The way I put is Jews are too isms want.
Italians are to operas it.
Jews.
Think about it.
Every ism Jews either created or lead
the except for Nazis,
communism,
humanism,
socialism,
live cap cap.
Well,
not.
Yeah.
All right,
fine.
But that's not an ideology.
That's just the,
an economic way.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
environmentalism,
feminism,
betty free.
Dan,
you know,
you,
you name it.
Trotsky.
Three of the possible successors to
Lennon at pamas death.
Three of the five.
There were only five people.
Three of the three of them commented,
synovium,
and Trotsky would choose Jews Bukhara
and install them.
We're not Jewish.
So in an odd way,
the Laurent,
you making an argument against religion
here because if the idea is that,
well,
this was the chosen group.
And look what you know as,
as,
what's his name?
Ms [inaudible] said in fiddler on the
roof.
So I wish we had been chosen for
something else.
Right?
Well,
isn't that actually an argument against
religion because the Jews were sort of
set up,
whether it's,
whether it's divine or manmade,
that there was a setup that guess what,
you're going to be exterminated and
kicked across the world.
And so if you would have asked,
ask me
if you would have a fight had been at
Sinai and I would have been told this is
what's going to happen to the Jews
because they are chosen.
I would have to.
God,
thanks.
But no thanks.
Have you been to Sinai?
Yes,
it is ironic.
Yeah.
Did you have any religious?
Because I'm not,
that's not the stuff.
I am moved by the text more than I am by
any,
uh,
physical place.
So,
uh,
but I'm atypical in that way.
I don't get old that choked up at,
uh,
at any monument or stuff like that.
Um,
all right.
So,
so one more thing on this and then we'll
move to a couple of other issues.
Um,
what do you think about also that the
story has been lost here?
What the actual history of the land is.
That's another thing that I try to
explain to people that you know,
you talk about the partition plan,
you talked about the fact that he was
British.
You're talking about that it was
actually part of the Ottoman Empire.
Before that there were no people called
the Palestinian people,
which people will say you're racist.
For they were Arabs there in a notice
that they were also Jews Palestinian in
1930.
The people notice as Palestinians were
the Jews and there were boys.
I mean you can look at New York Times
articles where the Arabs were boycotting
Palestine because it's so.
All of this stuff.
Even when I say it,
I feel like I'm already unleashing a
torrent of hate running,
but how do you beat people that won't
accept history?
How do you either.
There is only in this whole honesty,
there really is no way what we have.
What my,
my dream with prager university,
let's say,
or my radio show or anything that I do
publicly,
is to say what is true and I know that a
certain percentage of people will say,
wow,
I didn't know that.
Where is the majority will say,
Oh,
you are a coal you a bad name,
and that's what.
So you can only hope that the number of
people who will say,
oh,
I didn't know that I'm gonna change my
mind is greater than you imagined it
would be.
That's the only hope,
but it's dispiriting that facts don't
matter.
Hey,
a Hitler said Jesus was an Ra and not a
Jew,
and the Palestinians say he was a
Palestinian,
not a Jew.
Right.
The idea is it's beyond law.
Yeah.
It's,
it's entering a new realm.
Yeah.
And so do you think were post-truth?
Now that seems to be the new truth is
coming from the enemies of Western
liberalism.
It's not coming from the right who was
protecting western liberalism.
It's coming from the left and from the
Islamists.
That's the irony.
So let's critique the right a little
bit.
You've got to have some critiques of the
right.
Right.
I don't have that many critiques of the
Writing Center that they don't know how
to fight.
So then they,
they,
they don't,
they don't know what they stand for.
They forgot.
It's like,
it's like the choir forgot it's
melodies,
but by and large I have to say,
and I never thought I would have said
this is a kid,
you know,
growing up as a Jew in New York,
but the people on the right that I have
met,
uh,
of course there are exceptions because
they were disgusting people on the right
and they're beautiful people on the
left.
But by and large,
the people on the right that I have met
have been kind and decent and loving
and,
you know,
they give more charity.
They adopt more kids from a I,
I don't mean just general adoption
that's left and right,
but they adopt.
I was just with a right wing guy who,
uh,
he and his wife had two biological
children and then they adopted two more
children from China,
not newborns.
Kids with terrible illnesses that is
overwhelmingly done by religious
Christians in America.
It's not been done by Europeans.
It's not done by secular in America.
Of course.
I know there are exceptions,
but overwhelmingly a tiring having to
say that all the time.
I feel the same way.
Two billion it,
it drives me crazy cause then you,
you know,
you see yourself quoted and know you,
so you have to make,
you know,
it's like clarification for the foolish
but,
but in any event,
I've just been touched by the.
I'm a Jew,
I have been overwhelmed by the kindness
of so many evangelical Christians.
So,
so real quick,
let's just talk about what you just
mentioned there.
Just sort of being a public person where
you have to measure your words all the
time.
Was it always like this,
like when you were doing radio 30 years
ago,
did you feel that you had to constantly
qualify everything,
every adjective.
There was no internet to play.
Everything you've said and you know,
take it out of context or whatever.
But as soon as it developed,
I did take an even earlier than that.
I did start with a motto in my brain,
be sure that no one sentence can kill
you.
And I am very,
very careful about how I speak and I'm
amazed that in 33 years,
tens of thousands of hours of live is
not.
You can't do anything.
It's live radio.
They,
I have never been caught on a,
on something that could hang me.
You just jinxed yourself horribly.
Did you see?
I'm very,
I'm very scientific superstition.
Um,
do,
do you think that there's just a certain
amount of mental space that,
that takes up even having to think about
it because that's what I talk about
Swat.
One of the reasons I leave the show,
uh,
like I just went through,
I,
I am,
I work out harder in the show than with
my trainer at the gym just to see,
just to sort of contain the potential
errors.
It's a chess game if it's a three hour
grandmaster chess game,
and I suspect you would argue that all
of that has to do again with the left
and the buzzword because
they pinned everybody into it.
Look,
I wrote it
piece every so often I write pieces that
are nothing to do with politics or
religion or anything but have to do with
the private sphere.
So I wrote a piece about eight years
ago.
My syndicated column was a when a,
when a wife is not in the mood,
obviously for sex.
I got it.
So,
uh,
my argument is that if you love your
husband,
if you have a loving marriage,
he's a good man and knowing how
important sex is to him,
that even if you're not in the mood,
why not give it a try because we can't
be guided by moods.
It's,
you know,
and,
and I wrote what if you're not in the
mood to go to work,
but you know,
it's important.
You have to go to war.
So guess walk to the daily Co's,
they,
they read my piece and the daily
headlines,
prager advocates,
marital rape.
And then what do you do?
Do you spend any time trying to clean it
up or do you do
about possible to clean up the left?
However,
I will just say,
just for the record,
yeah,
there was a man at the daily Co's who
writes the road with the next issue or
whatever.
Next day,
next week.
I can't stand dennis,
prager,
rees,
right wing.
I can't stand them.
I want to make it clear.
I can stand them.
Did I say
can stand there and then says,
but give me a break.
The guy did not advocate marital rape,
so what does that say about just the
state of affairs in terms of the
Internet then because I'm.
I'm very enthused by the fact that I do
this show on the Internet and I can do
whatever I want and say we've got to
end.
The barrier to entry is low,
which is getting a lot of great people
involved.
Right.
That comes with a whole series of
problems because anyone can get in,
any idiot can put on a suit and sit at a
desk and pretend they know what they're
talking about.
So huge problems,
but when you think about just that
general state of that,
our media,
nobody trusts anybody anymore.
They.
Well,
that sort of trick is to learn who mia
can trust.
Yeah,
but it's not all that easy.
That's true.
That's why.
Look in the final analysis,
I always say credibility is your
greatest source of power.
The A and I have taken that very
seriously.
I don't take sponsors that I can
personally endorse A.
I said,
I say no to a lot of sponsors because
like I'll just give you an example.
I mean,
I hope I'm not hurting any sponsor here,
but uh,
we're fan funded so you're right,
but I'm not a sponsored funded.
But uh,
I was asked,
yes,
he was a perfect example.
I was asked to advertise your mattress,
a fine mattress I might add,
but I,
I,
I believe that I have the greatest
mattress in the world which I currently
do sleep on and I can't therefore say
this is the mattress I sleep on even
though they'll send me a free mattress.
It doesn't matter to me.
And I told them that.
I said I will happily say it's a fine
mattress,
but I will not say it's the best and I
will not say I sleep on it.
So I'm very,
very careful about credibility,
but it's hard to know whom,
whom you can trust.
Part of it is whom,
and you have to know a lot certain
things should strike you at the outset
as is,
that's,
that's a little too bizarre to be real.
And then you've got to verify it.
Yeah.
What do you make of just how people are
being funded by all sorts of crazy
things right now.
So you know,
like Pierre Omidyar finds Glenn
Greenwald's intercept.
I'm sure you probably don't love that
site roar,
you know,
whoever's funding salon or Al Jazeera
funds the young Turks or you know,
they have,
which is funded by part of the
government of Qatar or any of this stuff
that,
that's another problem we have that now
we don't know where money's coming from
with everybody.
Like just everything has been open to
it.
This is a real problem because
transparency is not the answer either
because as we found out in America,
and uh,
Kimberly Strassel of the Wall Street
Journal wrote a very powerful book on
this.
The transparency issue has given the
left a way to ruin the law wives of
funders,
of conservative foundations,
which we don't do the boycott their
houses,
uh,
announce publicly.
These are haters and people don't want
that misery in their lives.
That's the reason the left wants
transparency of donors.
So it's a very complex question,
even though they take plenty of money
from Soros and a whole series of other
things.
Also,
I think they've partly learned that this
stuff doesn't work because even when
Kellogg's just a couple of weeks ago,
or was it two months ago or so?
The thing with Breitbart.
Well then what happened while they're
breitbart?
People stopped eating.
Kellogg's.
I mean,
yeah,
but we'll,
we'll,
we've come into a place where companies
think they have to.
Well,
the political has also left created.
I don't care.
I don't care about if,
if,
if a company.
Look I.
This is my perfect example,
Ben and Jerry's ice cream.
Ben and Jerry,
if you go left and Ben and Jerry,
you're in London territory,
right?
I eat Ben and Jerry ice cream because I
don't believe that the free market
should allow me to boycott based on
their ideology.
But that's not what the left believes.
You,
you,
uh,
you supported trump.
We want you to be bankrupt.
That's how they think.
We will ruin your company.
So you,
while I'm sure you do not like any of
the ideas of Bernie Sanders,
they loved Bernie Sanders,
but you said,
I liked their ice cream.
I'm just going to eat their ice cream.
Basically.
That's my belief.
And,
and you can let it be at that and not.
Well,
that's the ideal.
That's was the American ideal.
The left has made that impossible.
The left is so constantly boycotting.
Anyone they differ with.
I mean,
why was it,
you know,
chick filet,
the guy believes that marriage should be
defined as male,
female and he should be put out of
phase,
not allowed in New York and Chicago.
I mean that's an absurdity.
If the guy advocate same sex marriage,
would I not eat his ice cream?
I'm a conservative religious
conservative.
So what?
Well that
such virtue signaling to.
I remember during that whole chick filet
thing and I was on o'reilly arguing
about chick filet and then shortly after
that I was on the young Turks,
which is a progressive network and
they're screaming about chick fil a the
whole time I'm openly gay and I worked
there.
I didn't care that much actually.
I just thought this is one of these
things that were just outraged about
whatever.
A guy walked into the production
meeting,
eating chick filet,
and I thought if anyone.
I mean guys,
I don't really care,
but like you're out there screaming
about chick filet and here you are
eating chick fil a way.
So that also shows sort of just like a
general inconsistent is that everybody
has across the board probably.
Right.
But I don't think the right boycotts
with,
uh,
with the instinct that the left does.
I mean,
I can't even think of an analogy.
It's just you take a position we don't
like,
we want you out of business.
Oddly Ben and Jerry's or big Israel
supporters,
are they,
they're big walk.
Are they big supporters of Israel?
They have a couple of accounts there.
I think so.
So they've confused.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so let's just,
let's just knock out a couple
bull other issues.
Let's just talk about hot topics.
So gay marriage,
uh,
as a man that I sent you don't govern by
the Bible.
That's sort of what you were saying
earlier.
Um,
but I don't think
values come from your values come from
the Bible,
but you're not governing.
Well,
yes and no.
I mean,
the Bible says do not murder governing,
you know,
it's a tough call,
but,
but if the Bible didn't exist,
I'm guessing the Dennis prager would not
be a murderer,
correct.
That.
No,
that's.
Well,
you're right.
But I'm not sure that society would have
created much,
do not murder emphasis of the toughest
group for the Catholic Church to convert
with a Germanic tribes of Europe because
they didn't buy the notion of the 10
commandments and specifically do not
kill,
do not murder,
which is really what it says.
Because they said,
what are you nuts?
If you're stronger,
you kill.
And there's no argument against that.
Only if you say,
well,
excuse me.
The creator of the universe says it's
wrong.
Woo.
Yeah.
But other than that,
it's not necessarily rolling.
So I don't know what I would think if I
had not been affected by,
by,
uh,
2000,
3000 years of the Bible.
I don't know the answer to that,
but I will be honest to this.
Uh,
the,
uh,
so I'm,
I'm sort of setting myself up to be
challenged here,
but it's okay if the Bible said nothing
about homosexuality,
the,
the odds are,
well,
no.
If the Bible said nothing about the
importance of male female distinction
and that's what I need to explain in a
moment.
Uh,
I,
uh,
my heart is with gay marriage.
Okay.
Uh,
my wife and I have a number and I don't
know people mock it,
but I don't.
Sometimes it's lockable,
sometimes it isn't,
but we're very close to two gay couples.
One female,
one male and the females,
my niece and then her and her wife and
uh,
the,
the male,
their partner,
they didn't get married but they,
they're like married.
What's the makeable part there?
No,
no,
when,
when anybody says some of my best
friends,
but we're so close to these couples that
it's,
you know,
if,
if I really objected,
it would be hard to be that close.
Right,
okay.
I mean,
if my heart,
my heart is with them,
let's put it this way.
So,
but my value system warned me,
and this is the key thing on,
I predicted this from the beginning.
I said,
the reason that same sex marriage
troubles me is primarily that it makes
the following announcement.
Gender doesn't matter,
because that is the argument whom the
gender of whom you married doesn't
matter.
That's the fundamental argument of same
sex marriage.
So far I'm okay with,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It's really logical what I'm about to
say.
This has nothing to do with the Bible.
It will in a moment,
but it has to still be logical even if
it's biblical.
So if gender doesn't matter in marriage
than gender won't matter,
period,
you have left the uh,
the proverbial a Bot.
Is it the horses out of the barn?
Once you announced gender?
Doesn't matter.
Well,
by Golly,
gender doesn't matter.
And now that's exactly what it said on
the progressive side.
Gender doesn't matter.
Do you know that in,
in thousands of schools in America,
teachers are told,
do not call your elementary school
students,
boys and girls call them students
because you cannot impose a gender
identity on them.
Let them choose their gender identity if
they want one later in life.
Right?
So I get the slippery slope thing there.
I get it.
I mean,
you can look at my twitter,
I mock these people all day long with
these ridiculous fried frame it came
from changing it in marriage.
Okay.
So that.
So there's sort of two things there.
There's the,
there's the original point about gay
marriage and then just the slippery
slope that.
So,
so let's just separate those two things.
So in terms of the gay marriage,
my feeling always was I should just be
treated equally under the law.
Makes make sense,
period.
I want to enter a contract with
somebody.
It happens to be a man,
right?
You unedited that same contract with and
I totally understand that and I,
but I knew going to happen and the price
is too great.
So I would,
I would want the gay persons have every
right.
And I know this is not the same as
marriage and I knew every argument that
I know every argument against it and
their sound they are,
it's to sound arguments against the
other.
But if I think macro,
not just micro,
my concern is not just the individual,
it's for the whole society and I'm
afraid the society has,
has chosen wrong in this matter because
of the gender doesn't matter issue.
So.
Okay.
So basically I sense you don't want to
say you don't particularly care because
you're a caring person,
doesn't,
it?
Doesn't bother you in,
in,
in the specifics of your.
In my home studio.
You were on my,
I live here with the names pumps.
They're both with these two couples as
with heterosexual couples.
And by the way,
for the record,
right before we started,
you asked me if I was married straight
or gay.
I didn't sense that you can do.
And then the immediate concern was how
did you meet?
I want to hear your romance.
I'm as interested as if it was a woman,
right?
Because the fist is my view.
You,
you and you are decent and compassionate
in the micro,
but you have to have standards in the
macro s and they are in this one
instance.
I don't know of another one I can think
of.
I can't think of one other and it's
related if you want to hear it,
it's unimportant,
but uh,
this is the biggest conflict that I ever
had and that's why I worked very hard on
this issue to learn what happened.
Uh,
what,
why the Bible took the stance that it
did.
But,
uh,
we,
meaning you and me,
whether you're straight or gay,
we are going to pay a price for the
death of gender.
The war against gender is a war against
civilization,
I believe.
Okay.
So now we're getting the slippery slope
portion of it.
So that part I would say,
do you think it's possible that if you
give people a chance that you let gay
people get married,
that the legitimate things that you're
talking about,
all these silly things.
I see this where they don't want,
they don't want to call them students.
I saw once where they wanted to call
them comrades.
Literally.
I mean,
so I get that release stuff and all the
labeling and all this nonsense,
but that may be if you let gay people
get married that they.
They would actually be allied with you
in it,
but they're not.
It's LG.
I said some of bb t yeah.
If it was lgb then they wouldn't be,
but the.
The see the activists,
you're separating the activists from
this.
They're the dominant voice and they're
the ones who have the boycotts and
they're the ones who get gaze angry or
black sangre or Jews angry or women
angry.
They're the anger creators,
the activists.
You and I would have no way.
We'd have a great life.
It's been a nonissue but.
But the activists or the anger creators
and they added the t and I asked,
well,
before this whole thing,
what does t have to do with LG and be.
I mean,
I had a show on Sirius xm that was on
the outcome channel.
The lgbt channel,
which I'm happy to say no longer exists
because gay people could have regular
radio shows,
so I'm glad that progress came so that
there was no need for ghettoisation of a
radio channel just for gay people.
Uh,
I always wanted to be on the political
channel anyway and they threw me on the
gauge channel,
so I'm fine with how it all worked out.
Yes.
Uh,
but I do remember while I assume you
rather be on our political channel than
a gate channel,
you're not defined by your gayness.
This is getting as I can.
I'm not even doing that good at it.
Wouldn't you rather be with someone a
little more fabulous than this if you
were to sit across from a gay guy for an
hour?
And I'm like,
no,
you want to be,
want to be normal,
whatever that is.
I mean,
I don't even like the word normal,
but normal
oil is not defined by your sexual
orientation.
Yeah,
that's what normal.
I don't.
I'm not saying heterosexual is more
normal by the way.
I actually believe bisexual is the norm.
So it's a very complex issue because in
every society prior to the Bible had
homosexuality was accepted.
So this is unknown,
this is truly an.
I didn't come up with this pro gay
professors did all the research for me.
Uh,
so I know all about this.
I devoted.
I devote a 17,000
word essay on this 30 years,
25 years ago.
This was a revelation to me.
I thought the Bible was merely
reinforcing the anti gay feelings that
permeated surrounding society.
But it was unique.
The Bible said,
men,
you pr,
you are as happy with boys.
I don't mean eight year olds,
15 year olds,
just as a grown man is happy with a 15
year old girl if that says homosexuals
and heterosexuals are identical,
uh,
but the,
but we are telling you we the Bible as
it were,
I'm telling you,
the Bible is telling,
you know,
confine your sexuality to your wife,
the Bible eroticized marriage.
So the line though that everyone goes
to,
if you're talking about gay marriage,
they always say,
well,
I'm going to butcher it slightly,
but don't lie with a man as you would a
woman.
Correct.
I don't lie with a woman that way.
So I haven't.
I gotten a little trick here,
isn't that?
Didn't I do a little talmudic trick?
That is its own music trick.
Pretty good.
Rough.
What do you got for that one?
Right?
Well,
don't lie with the women that way.
So it's not a problem.
I know the Hebrew,
not exactly that is the way it's often
translated,
but the Hebrew that I can get you and
they're going to come on a do not lie
with a male and then the key words,
and they're very rarely translated
accurately or Michigan v Dot Shaw.
The lighting's not as you would lie the
lines and it's plural,
which is interesting.
The lines of a woman do not lie with a
male,
the lines of a woman.
So it's not what you,
the gay person would do with a woman.
That's what men do with women.
But I almost had you there.
You almost did,
but then you would have.
If I didn't know that,
I would've thought to Shay that I would
add you.
All right,
so let's,
let's move on to another.
I think.
I think we got to where that says
couldn't agree more and that's also why
I wanted to discuss that with you
because I sent them.
We weren't going to fully agree on it.
Right.
But I'm so afraid of that,
but yes.
Well,
people don't hear what might be your
issue.
Look,
there are people on the right who
they're.
I hate to say this,
this bothers me.
There are people on the right who have
contempt for gays and and it's wrong.
It's biblically wrong.
It's humanly wrong,
and it does bother me.
Yeah.
So in a weird way though,
so trump on this must of give you a
little anxious because it's pretty
obvious.
I couldn't care less.
He could not give me any,
but it's not.
It's the supreme court has ruled it's,
it's a nonissue,
but it must be.
You asked in terms of that slippery
slope because it does give me an x,
but I'm not sure other than tweeting and
and by the way,
maybe one day he will tweet it.
I wish he would tweet.
Guess Swat teachers can call kids in a
lot of our schools,
boys and girls anymore.
What do you think about America?
I would like him to tweet that.
Yeah,
so that.
That's actually a good segue to A.
I'll put the other one aside for a
second,
but some of the political correctness
stuff,
because this is directly affect.
I mean it's been a sort of through line
of everything we've been talking about
here,
but it also directly affected your
channels.
So the prager u channel you guys,
and again you're doing videos to explain
things.
I've watched many,
many of your videos.
I'm in one next month.
I mean,
so I've never seen any hatred.
People could argue with some of the
facts if they want or they could argue
if maybe you're coming from a certain
political persuasion or any of that,
but I've never seen anything remotely
close to hate speech or hate trade or
any of the stuff that would get you
banned or whatever.
You guys were,
weren't banned from twitter,
but you were restricted,
restricted.
Show it in schools or libraries.
I mean,
it's mind blowing.
We have a video on the origins of the
Korean War.
Yeah.
What's,
why is that restricted?
So what's happening here with.
Look,
this show is on youtube,
so I don't want to make the Youtube
God's to angry day.
They won't be angry,
but it's a very look that I was sure the
Wall Street Journal had a feature that
editorial on behalf for Prager
University,
uh,
saying,
what does youtube doing?
What are you,
what are you nuts?
Because a lot of Wall Street Journal
people have break state Bret Stephens
system on a Kimberley strassel has done
one and and others.
And so they know about us.
What are you,
what are you kidding?
A youtube video units.
So what do you think is actually
happening?
Leftists are meeting at the top of
youtube saying no,
I think that there are all left this to
troll the,
uh,
the webs,
the websites,
especially among those that are
successful.
And we're the biggest producer of
conservative videos in the world.
I'm $220 million views last year.
That's a serious number for anybody even
for the left and uh,
and so they know that we exist.
And so if one bugs them then uh,
you know,
they just,
say,
uh,
I don't know,
bad material or objectionable or
hateful.
And if they get enough of those,
there's an algorithm that says,
okay,
we got,
we got reports.
They don't think they sit there,
they don't monitor them.
They get,
they get feedback and so leftist who
want to shut us down,
send this feedback,
but it.
But once they're contacted,
once the Wall Street Journal,
they then had another editorial.
They'd three editorials on behalf of
Prager University in the Wall Street
Journal.
That's a big newspaper.
And of course not one liberal newspaper
has,
but the,
so they're not liberal there left a
liberal paper would come to our defense.
So that to me is a great example of what
the difference between that freedom is
the biggest issue because it's free
speech now we're talking about for.
Yes,
that is correct.
And that's where,
of course they should.
Right.
And it isn't even,
you know.
Well,
let's let the Nazis March in Skokie,
Illinois,
which precedes your day.
Are you familiar with that?
Okay.
So there's a big Jewish area,
including a lot of survivors of the
Holocaust,
lived there,
the Nazis in,
in their grave evil,
you know,
had a march neonazis matter march there.
And uh,
the,
the acl you fought on their behalf,
but now freedom of.
But so,
but we're not in that category,
these little Haiti or as you point out,
there was something.
Do you know the most hated video that
we've put out?
This is,
I would never have predicted this.
I'm sure it's going to be a wonderful
irony.
Yes,
it will be our video on advocating that
men get married that has the most amount
of hateful comments directed against it.
Interesting.
So you guys also did a video on the
electoral college.
They are with that.
What I saw was about what?
$40 million caught some fire on that,
right?
So I see a lot of celebrities now
tweeting that it says white supremacist
way of controlling everybody.
And so you don't have to repeat the
whole video.
We'll put the link down below so people
can get hold of this country was not
found that to be a democracy was founded
to be republic and it was.
So what does that mean for people that
don't have democracy?
Is One man,
one vote,
that's all,
you know.
A plurality determines everything.
There were checks on,
on how it works in this country.
The most non democratic thing we is the
US Senate,
uh,
senator from Wyoming has the same vote
as a senator from California,
although California has 50 times more
people,
right?
So by the way,
I do believe if the left gets rid of the
electoral college,
they will vote to get rid of the Senate.
Yeah.
And then basically Wyoming and Montana
and all these places will have almost no
power.
Well,
that's the point of this was set up to
be the United States of America.
It's not just America,
it's states states now the left has
taken the word states' rights and they
have made it into a neo Nazi term,
which is what they did with almost every
tradition.
Nazis,
states rights.
Right?
Well,
that's the theory.
Yeah.
What's the theory there?
Oh,
I've heard that.
Oh yeah.
Because then the federal government
cannot suppress your racism.
Oh,
I see.
So you could just use your own racist
state,
right?
Yes.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
uh,
but that's not what America was founded
to beat.
And uh,
you,
you know,
that outside of this is amazing.
Outside of the four burroughs,
four of the five boroughs of New York
City and La and La County,
trump won the country.
Yeah.
Just outside of that.
So then,
so,
so you realize that's all you have to
win is New York and La and if there's no
electoral college,
that's all you'll campaigning.
What Michigan,
how do you spell it?
Right.
So you'd really have a less democratic
in the final analysis.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you know that you have to appeal to
more people with an electoral college.
That's what they wanted.
Yeah.
Um,
the fact that trump got,
what is it now,
is it 3 million less votes?
5 million left.
So really you don't.
Do you think that affects his mandate in
any way or just it is what it is
and if you,
if it's like,
you know,
I don't understand it.
My team,
our team had more home runs than the
other team.
Is that right?
Right.
Crazy.
There's other ways to score based on
home runs.
Yeah.
If it were based on popular vote,
he would have campaign in New York and
California.
But you,
you have to,
you win or lose on the rules going in.
Yeah.
Do you sense that because as you said
earlier that there's been nothing like
this before,
that there's incredible opportunity to
do good for the country right now.
I don't know that trump will grasp that
opportunity.
You sense that?
Because I,
I did not.
I did not support trump.
I didn't really,
I didn't support Hillary.
I really didn't like either one of them.
I don't even think I said this publicly,
but I ended up voting for Gary Johnson,
which I wasn't,
which believe me I was not happy about
and I think in a weird way he did the
most disservice to the country because I
think if there was ever a year for a
libertarian to explain some classical
liberal values and small government and
all that stuff,
I think this was the year to get some
ideas out there,
eat and he failed
miserably.
Um,
but the day after the election,
even though I didn't support trump,
I suddenly felt like there's some
movement here at least is the risk.
You can feel the tectonics shaking.
So how do you,
how do you take that out?
I hope in fact,
that that will take place.
I do have.
I now have hope change.
Yeah.
That's what I said at the top of the
show.
There's actual change now.
Yeah.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
Uh,
he has one quality that I like.
Yeah.
He doesn't care what the New York Times
it says about him.
That's where as I believe all the other
17 candidates did.
But what about the free speech stuff
with him?
Because it's one thing to be for free
speech when you're an opposition and
it's cool,
but now that he's the president,
I mean fighting with the reporters and
stuff like that.
Do you not see that?
So I don't like a lot of these people do
and I know the main reporters and
suppressing free speech have nothing to
do with each other.
Well,
the idea that the president would go
after specific reporters or specific
publications,
the chilling effect basically that that
would have over people that might be
critical of the president.
You don't see that as.
No because they don't get.
They don't get their viewers from the
president.
On the contrary,
for people on the left to be attacked by
trump is a badge of honor,
that's not even a related issue and he
should go after them by name if they're
rolling.
I mean he,
if he's rolling then he will look bad.
But if CNN reports,
uh,
what buzzfeed says and it's the only
major network to report the buzzfeed
what I believe is a lie than,
than CNN,
which I go on regularly.
So I have nothing against CNN,
but they should pay a price.
Do you think we need stronger liable
laws then?
Because I'm a,
I'm a free speech absolutist.
You can say whatever you want as far as
I'm concerned,
but I'm starting to think that this
system,
we're now going back to what we said
earlier about,
you know,
people funding different websites,
like just the system of constant lying.
Well,
not within the criteria for a,
for libel in America are almost
impossible to meet.
Yeah.
So I,
I've felt well mold before I,
I knew Donald Trump.
I never watched the apprentice.
I didn't know really anything about
them,
but I,
I felt that this country.
I think that there are a couple of
things from England,
England has stronger libel laws,
they may be too strong a England has a
loser,
pays in courts,
which I think should be,
should be the issue in,
in civil disputes and so on.
If somebody sues you and they turn out
to be wrong,
why should you have had to pay your
lawyer bills?
I think you would cut down the number of
frivolous lawsuits in this country by 50
percent.
I think there were things we could learn
from other systems.
I think libel laws might be one of them.
Yeah.
If I mean,
if I say,
you know,
uh,
I saw you abusing children,
wha,
why should,
why should I not be brought to court for
libel?
Yeah.
It's funny.
I just didn't last two or three days.
Somebody wrote a on a fairly decent
website that I'm a white supremacist and
I was about to publicly attack them.
I mean,
I'm a white supremacist.
This is like absurd beyond imagination
and I thought I can either now attack
them and get them to clicks,
which is what they so desperately want.
In another situation,
if I had a lawyer and a ton of money,
I guess I could sue him for lab or I
Oregon,
just do nothing and let it be and that's
what I did and I'm sure you could white
supremacy.
Well maybe that's an interesting
quality.
There was a bunch of other things there,
but it will be close enough.
You know,
if there was no evidence,
people say to me,
you'll,
you'll really love this.
I get this comment a lot where somebody
will come up with,
oh Dennis,
I love you.
I got,
you know,
my wife is a witness.
I get it a lot.
It's very sweet and I'm very touched by
a book.
Then they will often it.
Oh,
but everybody tells you that it's
actually that is not drew type in
Google,
Dennis Prager Asshole,
and you will get tens of thousands of
just do it through an image search on
that and then I think,
oh,
that would be the what?
I never thought of that.
Yeah,
that's a whole other.
I'm sure there's volumes.
I won't suggest that.
Yeah,
well you know what I had I had a ton
more to talk to you about,
but instead of looking at these now and
I know some of them off the top of my
head,
we'll do this again.
How about that?
I would love it.
I really would.
Yeah.
All right,
well,
terrific.
I would love that.
Thanks.
Likewise.
All right,
well it's been a pleasure talking to
dentists and you can check out the
prager u videos.
We're going to put the link right down
below and don't forget to comment and
like and all that good stuff.
So the algorithm doesn't kill us and
follow it down.
It's on twitter.
It's at Dennis prager.